يخنق بوتين الضوء والحياة
من هنا ،
نحن نقود إلى دخان
هجوم بالذخائر الحارقة ، قيل لنا
هنا ضد حقول منازل هذه القرية المدنية ،
حتى الهواء نفسه الذي أحرق
فييرا تقول إنها شاهدتها تسقط من
السماء وضربت جارتها
شرقًا حرفيًا ،
جاءت الذخيرة الحارقة التي تحترق من
خلال كل شيء في طريقها
بعد قصف عادي ثقيل مما
يجعلك تتساءل كثيرًا هنا بالضبط
لماذا احتاجت روسيا إلى تسخين النار فوق
المتفجرات الثقيلة
التي أصابتها قبل 10 دقائق فقط ، يقول هذا الرجل وهو
يشير إلى الطريق  هذا
في اللحظات الأولى من الصدمة ،
فالنتينا أمر واقع للغاية لأنها
تصف ما حدث للفوز في
منزل جارتها ،
حيث تظهر لنا الفناء حيث
يرقد رجل ميت حفرة كبيرة في صدره
وأذن
ممزقة تشير إلى  الجسد خلف
الشجرة
مباشرة ثم يقول من هو
المنتصر قد هرع للتحقق
من منزل جارهم الذي
احتلته روسيا هنا لأسابيع وبينما
تتراجع هذه الزوايا الصغيرة  اللون الأخضر هو
المكان الذي يزور فيه غضبه
على الطريق المؤدي إلى مواقع روسيا
الأخيرة قبل الحدود ، تسقط
القذائف حتى
توفي زوج ناتاليا الأقرب في قصف
منذ أسابيع ، وكان منزلها تقريبًا مثل
كل شيء هنا مدمر
لأسابيع عندما كانت هنا
محتلة عبر  الشارع من قاعدة روسية ضخمة
مرشدونا من وحدة الاستجابة السريعة الأوكرانية
حذرون من أن القتال
يتصاعد على الطريق وهم يعلمون
أن الروس مرتاحون هنا
حتى أن قاعدتهم احتاجوا إلى
جهاز تحذير للطائرات عاليًا ليخبروا
الطائرات الروسية أنها كانت ودية هذه هي
مشكلتهم  في كل مرة يتقدمون فيها إلى الأمام هنا
يكونون في ما كان يومًا ما
موقعًا روسيًا وينظرون حولك من
المستحيل معرفة من الذي
يتحكم حقًا في هذه المنطقة مع حدوث قتال
على الجانب الآخر من
التل ورائحة الجثث بين أشجار الصنوبر
تحت كل خطى ، فإن خطر الألغام في
كل مكان تنظر فيه إلى صناديق ذخيرة الخنادق
بوضوح قاعدة روسية مهمة
هنا  إنك تسميها بلدة صغيرة
تستخدم هذه الغابة كغطاء ولكن من
الواضح أنها ضربت
بشدة قبر الجنود الروس المجهولين ،
وهذا يقول
آثار مروعة هنا حيث كانت
ذات يوم تعج بالمهمة الوحشية الخرقاء المتمثلة في
محاصرة مدينة
مشتعلة في الأشجار هنا ولكنها
ابتلعت  في صمتهم الطويل